what's up fool what's a full podcast
welcome to the words are full podcast we
have a guest today she'll be here later
we got mark - rizal filling in for
Rodrigo Torres yeah a lot of filling in
to do for Rodrigo what's up fool we need
three of you dog we got Lisa over here
chillin we're here with the ball I want
to thank everybody who went out and
watched gente fight we were number five
on Netflix oh yeah I still today I think
number five everybody man everybody know
they told me they been on that showing
in one day you see all of them already
I've only seen the first episode I just
haven't had time but Stephanie she
watched all of them and she told me it's
what it's like really good episode I
think it's five I saw just a little part
of it I was crying yeah I like watching
some that said in Los Angeles you know
that's like my favorite I might have I
mean I know that I know or sometimes you
watch like where they're driving
somewhere and they pop up and another
tray of those in its not around and I
wait always every movie everything I
know where that shot even if it's not
supposed to be soon sometime when they
say it's all AI know in that only yeah I
was watching now was it the movie with
our average ends almost what's called
the East LA movie he's a teacher
yeah he's driving like on Whittier one
then and then the other D turns and he's
like somewhere else I'm like movies not
believable anymore heavily and they got
this wrong where does it they get wrong
yeah I was about to when they're driving
and then they're like get East LA and
like you save and then let you know like
they go under a tunnel and then I even
though the beach yeah we don't come on
lie to me was an amusement park whatever
that's not a cruise yeah that's funny
that's why I like people talking about
the fascinating for his movies for the
first one that's like la la man that's
Elliott Lee the first fest in the furies
yeah before we got done before we got
like super sci-fi I was like super a
furious sci-fi I never watched one of
them but I know once I find the new ones
kind of jump the shark and it's like
they are like they're jumping out of
like airplanes and they have superpowers
now yeah the new ones yeah they have
super powers like they're like what's it
called jumping out win ten story like
buildings and like landing like on there
like now it's like they got like a new
rider because like the first thing wants
really like realistic and then after
that like the biggest thing they did was
like hijack trucks and steal DVD players
and sell them like and now it's bugging
they're like saving like the government
I don't know it's crazy baby boys doing
it yeah yeah Tyrese yeah those guys like
shooting like missiles from cars now
it's it's the ides it's super like I
can't remember Tyrese name without
saying variable at first that ghetto ass
dude bro like I met that girl ass dude
that doesn't remember nobody from no
movie Rose no no name like oh [ __ ] like
if I were a star keep up it which is
almost when it when I'm working me first
Kim oh oh the ghosts are Donna haha a
star Donna they heard when it dropped
you homie ha ha that's funny dude
I remember yeah what's it called all
those movies I don't know if it was
[ __ ] like a like something up block
was here that day like some ghetto guy
that he will let it's like rain like
these rated R movies all the time you
might cousin we're kids to nest Oh ha no
really trying to touch me Nestle yeah I
think it's a tree coup but I was just
like corny for everybody like you want a
guy or a girl you didn't care man yeah
it was progressive as [ __ ] dude I
remember out Chris progressive but
problematic at the same time
yeah but do I remember you talked about
like Bisons don't care I don't care huh
no they're just everywhere like I'm ever
gonna flock oh you silly humping each
other like when I have to work at a
restaurant with a bunch of pies
they're always humping each other
restaurant I was working over there on
my way no they were like humping each
other
ooh la porte de la pila the dominican
guys in New York did the same thing
they're just they're always doing that
or calling each other money gone money
go nah so the grab-ass and they would
SWAT each other with towels oh yeah back
there I remember do everyone follow
we'll go home together yeah Flaco used
to live in k-town and I was walking to
my car right and this little Python is
little beat-up car pulls up to this like
tall what's it called uh what's it
called prostitue happens to be a guy you
know yeah what's the correct term now I
don't know what to say transsexual
gender transgender prostitute and you
wouldn't in
know so he pulled up and in the target
ah prostitute got inside let up Isis
Carney took off like damn this guy knows
a guy for sure you know damn fool that
fool right there he picked Isaac Guillen
shoutout to eyes again he's listening
right now on Facebook that full said was
some sand crab brought back in the day
these guys you know everybody said
what's up Robbie like what some sand
crab yeah right because they were all
dirty Oh so everybody to the sand crab
uh-huh that fools a bigger liar dogs oh
yeah yeah bro open
why did not listening buy them what time
it was some guy named Rafa [ __ ] yeah
used to work at my high school there
yeah so crazy
Emilio Garcia he's from mom he lives
over there and I have weird Garvey I
don't know some where I live I rose mean
no piling so probably go to Kipple oh
it's probably Monterey Park around in
that area and this fool showed up bro
and he was not the Mo's the guy that was
in che bro yeah you know
Dobin shaker but they're full said that
he was raped by three girls bro
how old was this guy I don't know we
were in high school you must buy three
girls yeah bro my teachers are like what
I don't know bro no very song resign
these are the cops he was like this here
three women attacked him bro and you
need and they sexually assaulted him the
three witches from a hocus-pocus never
got to words I shut up you liar
oh yeah they're a little Finnish you say
bro he did happy for you I swear
yeah man so that Nam Oh dog we weren't
as bad as ditching party dog uh-huh
there was some guy I forgot his name but
I'm a [ __ ] I'm from Garfield High
School a party doll yeah like there
might be the rival high school board car
Garfield knows how to party knows how to
power their shoes
shut up to GHS East Los Angeles
Roosevelt High School the easterly
classic what man but um no this dude in
our in our he was like perfect way bro I
don't know they had when you and you
were in school but there was so many
students in a Garfield High School and
so many students and rows of our high
school that they got up they had to
break up the kids who couldn't find a
class and make about their own school or
like a contingent high school we had our
own school and East LA college it's like
an extension oh we got bused to row to
East LA college bro the one in no one
actually needs to lower the one in South
Gate cuz there's no East LA college oh
really oh [ __ ] we had aa is there school
there are classes on campus of East LA
cuz we have
longer lows right yeah the bungalows
were the high school really they're like
we had to cut to cut our college Nova so
we were getting extra credit broke our
ass handed so they're so the people that
do a long ass hair bro like The Ramones
bro like just long as here yeah wear the
beanie looking like crazy Dave from
enterprise a guitar with a turtle back
it was a nice guitar brah and would you
start hanging out with him bro it we are
going to his house so so you're hanging
out with old guys know that guy oh
here's a car dog hi taking those places
he has like a bad dog I'm that wagon
Bob ugh that's good that's I ruin a
person a dog named I Rona ha ha I'm so
high I'm gonna know the guy there who
was like one of those meat glow looking
guys yeah he was a meek low looking guy
and he lived over there by an Atlantic
bro we went to his house what did you go
and do a lot of beer bro yeah
a lot of be like 21 year old guy 22 year
old man we're all underage okay so
there's no culture as you hung out there
that guy was like maybe 19 oh yeah but I
was at someone else's pad brothers I was
at home yeah we were drinking dog and
man I drank a lot of beer
and I saw some girl I liked her through
and then threw up
ma'am I probably I peed in my pants
whatever but this dude we're all doing
Papa will is broken I had three bikes
like a mousse whatever huh so this food
gets on their bike falls down and breaks
his leg and psycho dog
yeah so man oh man we got my entire
story though laughs I and Amelia and I
go through the party they put the food a
wheelbarrow bro
oh yeah Hospital I did the Wilbur a
wheelbarrow nice tell ya a farm
yeah it's construction that's funny dude
that's cool you're younger and you do
that like that he I'll make breakfast
just a were party in the middle of the
house man we're drinking for these dogs
like I don't know 20 19
I think so but after my continued up
what about night school yeah sorry
pounding bro like 40 ounces of
everything
uh-huh and then that fool had a cousin
that looks just like angel so you know
right away uh-huh and it was a party
more and I was trying to listen to a
bunch of punk music so Rocco was there
too
yeah bro that food said I got breakfast
in the morning so everybody tired I'm
gonna buy breakfast before everybody but
in there being that I'll cook breakfast
fine what's that dude yeah was it like a
Johnny rocket movie I remember like I
went to those like ghetto punk parties a
lot huh sternly
yeah I do like Easter lame Boyle Heights
and we're like I told you a long time
ago like there's these it's only cholos
I get in the mosh pit and like my friend
Alice got felt gonna be funny so he
began push me inside the mosh pit I got
[ __ ] up by cholos bro
you got beat up yeah I got [ __ ] up by
trolls dude and looking like I just got
jumped in a gang be well those cholos in
so there was a mosh pit in East Los
Angeles by
showed in high school imagery the this
high school was probably by by sure bro
all right in Montebello so those parties
are freaking like crazy
shut up to know the Miguel Eduardo his
shoes burger
Oh a mondo Marko's tanto for listening
to the podcast on Facebook live
everybody right here go to Facebook live
okay
shout out to Fe Li nosy Contreras all
right home in a key Facebook vivo we're
here you're going on another one today
is Ash Wednesday people I'll be selling
bootleg ashes outside I'm outside of
church so anybody out there when you get
to church is the mess a big-ass I I got
you man I'll be out there with all my my
ashes for my blood bless blood and we
got you dog eat dog man there's some
churches there is so many people show up
yeah I do that they pass out wristbands
bro yeah do the church it needs till I
used to go to you're out control right
yeah it's insane doing those people
start outside stuff like the church you
try to get it done before work right
they'll get it done early in the morning
or after work yeah what's up my dad you
just over the head but him being less
yeah I keep that one topic I get my mom
sent my brother my littlest brother
Davis to Catholic school and fifth and
sixth grade because he was hyperactive
and he was pretty much getting he wasn't
able to sit in regular classes in public
schools so they didn't know what to do
with them so they suggested like a
stricter education so they suggested
Catholic school and and my mom got a
scholarship we were not Catholic she got
a scholarship to send bad ass and
because we were poor but he goes to this
school and he comes home one day and
he's got ashes on his head and my mom we
freaked out it looked like he was part
of a call to him at that school and like
we had no clue we didn't know any
there's no Google back there no
I mean we didn't know much about
Catholicism and all we didn't know a lot
of Catholics and we were seventh-day
Adventists so yeah it's like where we
were the cult I'm not cold but you know
we were the odd ones out the minority
but it was freaky to see him walking out
there and even in New York everybody's
Catholic over yeah yeah everybody's got
and when I would when Ash Wednesday
would come around it just seemed odd
like this thing I was not part of yeah
like the Horde of believers you know
they see your movie could Scientology
kind of thing they all have the mark
yeah it's timeless
there's so many other things besides I'm
Ash Wednesday is going down it's a
little celebration in New Orleans Fat
Tuesday Fat Tuesday Mardi Gras yeah and
then there's yesterday yesterday and
there's another one too by some other
religion parties um next week also but
you can't do better what is it about
Jesus to like the yeah okay you know
it's funny man when we were over there
and now we're in North Carolina and then
where we were and I'm Chicago I guess
New Orleans has our own bread it's
called king bread it looks like the Slee
like rosca that bread that we have for
up there that days for all three three
kings drinking among all the wise men
day I thought that's what it was I'm
sorry it's all and that's not all saints
days yeah yeah so the bread is like God
Lakers colors is purple yeah a little
bit of green yeah I guess it's like that
one if you if you bite into a daiquiri
you got throw a party for Fat Tuesday
[Laughter]
that's a funny dude yeah but like I
wanted a brother
I wanna buy that little sample brother
had like for $3 it to taste it oh I try
see how I take full of exude full eggs
full of sugar and like what's it called
that green stuff I don't know that is I
don't know that they have their own
bread so it's all similar you know
maybe maybe there's some kind of little
connection right yeah Jesus you gotta
give something up of your mom or your
dad or anybody and you ever give away
anything for quite as ma or gave a
anything up for Lent
yeah my dad we were little kids he'll
give up alcohol every four days I
brought he was miserable bro for 40 days
beating the [ __ ] out of us I did going
to the track instead like racing or
sister sending a race track look at
Sunita yeah he lived over there too you
live over there friend friend's boat all
right my dad friend we'll all go in one
car and come back like easy money buddy
ah yeah I have my promise that I talk to
all the debris go Vinny you hit your
prom at 72 racetracks yeah he'll go
backward there and they had to called
from there go play with your date come
in bro
yeah after problems an egg I went to
high school for five years for high
school five years that blends me right
no so what happened was I went to
condition high school and I [ __ ]
I used to ditch so much I couldn't
graduate so I had to stay another year
cuz I was a good tutor so let me stay
another year
so I want c3 proms the last prime out to
be a chaperone to you bro the horse
probably was a live driver but my
problem I mean yeah if you pry at their
promises party after party and people
will start like shooting up what's it
called like people robbed but they
brought guns so dad other people the
[ __ ] students yeah it's like rival
gangs yeah I was crazy
no no after-party
Highland Park it was like in 2006 so it
was like before like it got really
gentrified
yeah yeah that's when I moved into home
bro around that time oh really
yeah I remember - those essays bro I
think I don't know if I were with Lisa
or no I bought a house and then well I
bought a house in 2004 and then 2006 I
went there to meet someone there with
her with I'm Ivan Cuellar uh-huh and
we're gonna meet somebody there for
something and he made an attempt at a
bowling alley and I'm a parking I'm a
[ __ ] dirtiest bowling alley parking
light no [ __ ] world then we'll have
some good bowlers in there yeah duty at
the bowling alley brother that the
better the bowlers and the alcohol and
the Chinese food inside the stellar the
nachos the better than everyone got to
go inside hilum bowling right however
but now they fixed it up right it's all
right nice super hipster like you can
you can have a problem there for sure do
yeah for sure horrible places so you're
probably that says I need a racetrack
yeah finish line
yeah the finish line yeah yeah yeah yeah
you graduation so what no when they're
choosing the prom king and queen I was
like no the way they're like they have
the jockeys or the number one half
everybody do the hats yeah but that's
how what was your prompt did you go to
problem why didn't graduate dog but did
you still go to a prom though hell no
bro I've had I never been to a prom but
I remember there was this woman well
she's a grown man she was a little girl
she brought I think she was driving
around with an extra ticket trying to
find a date oh yeah and she finally made
to the projects bro oh yeah she wants to
hit up everybody by Dakota junior high
school thank you everybody from Bob with
your junior high school everybody I'm
back I'm from Harlem back I'll have her
high school and then she drove to the
projects I guess since she was looking
for a prom be like yeah I'm sure she saw
me bro I was well I was doing I was
putting enough clothes on clothes pins
uh-huh hanger the wooden clothespin yeah
bro like that my mom was Japanese doing
laundry and I was doing putting putting
whatever about my mother you know
Ebru a lot did she care dog no no do I
remember like nobody scolded me for not
graduating or not
getting on my case like do you like did
you give any speech no I thought I got
somebody pregnant first day uh-huh by
that time I also graduated me the words
so the worst news was that so that
growth driving around and I'll put it up
whatever I'm close oh wait yeah she said
Philippe would it do it tonight he goes
you got 75 bucks hell no right but 75
bucks back then whatever it was dog yeah
that's priceless
no all right then uh-huh we didn't need
it for oh I never nice to take it for
the prom I don't wanna go to waste I
want to start it with somebody
uh-huh and I saw you outside so that she
would ask you to somebody else
yeah it went that's a funny man somebody
with ditched or something yeah did you
wait right I did three Oh Bob I would
the first one the first one I what's it
called it was with a girlfriend I had
the second one was with an it so had
three different girlfriends in high
school I was like James Bond every movie
was a different girl dude
but uh the last one was the most ghetto
one the first one was the first one we
had a prom at this one place in a
al-mansur park it was like a banquet
hall that's what the bye-bye-bye-bye
Elysian Park
no no this was in Hamburg al-mansur Park
it's like by like these Lakes by the
golf course out there hmm I think you
guys said you guys were gonna you guys
were looking to get married right yeah I
think I saw something that was like that
yes as a wedding venue yeah that's a
cool little area but yeah that's funny
man Alf see he's deeply got the plumbing
to the mail bro oh yeah he'll wait
outside with for the bill members tuxedo
bro
and then the male may open up in would
they blow my anyone are you graduated
haha it was like an Oscar Award yeah man
my high school is ghetto because it was
a continuation high school situations go
through a pregnant huh pregnant so I do
so and I tell people it's kind of pretty
girls in your class right so it's just
people who are at risk of dropping out
rich dropping out back here's our people
with our dad yeah I gangsters cuz I
remember like in school all the bad kids
that would disappear you never if you
don't like tagging yeah yeah so all
those kids would disappear no you just
forgot about them and when you go there
that's all where they were all how does
it all these people trying some of them
were trying or they just were there
because they had some of them cuz I have
to some of them they were trying and I
remember I just like it was the eve of
billion house for those x-men yeah yeah
it was like a lot ever there's a lot
aging gangsters I'm where I was sitting
like nixies gangster Asian gangsters are
tomahawk like over the weekend they
[ __ ] up something real bad like I need
a graduate dude
it was scary man yeah I wonder why they
even went cuz like I don't know how
maybe how long this you know what when
you're 15
you gotta somehow I guess I'm every year
the the city or the state allows the
amount of money to come school yeah so
they got these drop-offs bro so they're
losing our money so they make up this
school to keep putting that money yeah
yeah and now you can't force a kid after
a certain age to go to school I knew I
knew fifteen or sixteen now here in
California I know yeah because Isaac has
been talking about wanting to drop out
and I'm just 15 - age really think it's
I think it's 16 maybe but anyway it's 15
or 16 cuz I was my mother cuz I always
hear stories about my mom seeing like
how they gonna put her job I don't go to
school because I you see [ __ ] a lot
where did you go skateboarding
skateboarding just go do just not the
stupid [ __ ] I used to just go out and
then like when school and I will go and
hang out from this school like I don't
know why I will go back to the [ __ ]
scene of the crime but the day seem is
one guy called super narc he was like a
Native American guy that were like yeah
he will jump the fences and try to catch
it like super north
super narc for all your somebody you
work for the school you I don't know
their job Tara's are truant officer I'll
usually what they use
but super Narcoossee jump or they like
they used to come super narc or the
t1000 because the ec like see from far
away because he had hair binoculars and
he would always like got be on top of
the the tallest building and like for
kids that you name we will run after you
know scary dude you worst you know
America now look at me I'm [ __ ] the
movie without Dan the liver yeah when I
Lou Diamond Phillips the job is on foon
they jump over that fence yeah okay that
everywhere was it jumped over the fence
that's some hollaback junior high school
oh yeah and we used to walk through
there to another class that little area
right there know this there's narc from
the class the photos like a scoop
released my boy was a lot of people in
the neck yeah oh man bro he looked like
[ __ ] back like Batman's dad Bruce
Wayne's dad oh yeah that movie
Thomas Wayne let Tom I know for reals
and that for you to always catch food
that they're smoking weed really like
catching a bro mmm-hmm a weed spot back
then so home bag junior high that's
crazy dude boss telling you man back how
about you has been known to for like
there was like a big ham ball court you
know look at the cholos playing yeah
yeah yeah they're like five handball
courts and they're made of cement bro so
it a lot of professional cholo have our
players who make it to Folsom Prison
come on all about you know high school
that's a Donald Trump all right there
those big ass mugging conquer waabri can
you climb over that [ __ ] no let you go
to a sign and Clementine spider-man yeah
those are like actual [ __ ] like like
Costco walls right there bro what's up
fool we had an awesome time in Chicago
but we were really in Schaumburg barn
shy tell me one day we went to our
Saturday morning we went to the the home
alone house do all that bad ass I first
you guys were they don't want to go you
guys were like thinking it was gonna be
lame but it was fun dude
one house on with Winnetka it's on
whenever in Winnetka yeah in Winnetka
wooden Iike one equal he car why he got
in Winnetka shut up dude DJ Mambo from
Rick where mama baby Daniel you know
we're gonna be an oxen are four so we
might
know that you want to go I'm down there
the hitters up what's up fool also man
help if I go watch head to fine ooh
we're number five like the whole look
again so the whole thing about Chicago
like people go to like downtown to go to
the bean but I feel like people like
people grew up with the [ __ ] home
alone house so they have more of a
connection with the house and deal with
the bean you know right yeah yeah man
nobody sees the metal beam yo a lot of
people who live in Chicago that we met
oh man we never even been there we
didn't know that you can go yeah what
the [ __ ] dude well yes I guess the other
of Logan neighborhood in Chicago and um
little village still to the south side
north side end up going to the rich side
exactly oh man so we went to the home
alone house and as soon as we got there
there was a guy a Sikh I don't know you
know what a Sikh is is the guy that
wears a turban and a flute making the
home alone face like went like this
yeah when it was in our mouth open and
we shot a video there also we went to a
supermarket where McCulloch cocaine
Kevin he was a toothbrush he was it's
working and also he by summer he buys
like all the groceries and the ladies
like where's your parents that yeah I
forget what he says but yeah and then we
went to the the park where he ran from
yeah the park where he slid on his knees
it was a fake pond and then after that
we went to the we went to a lot of
places it's pretty much a home alone to
her bro yes we went to an airport of
course yeah there you go oh here the
people like new people like the videos
that we did this weekend yeah man shy
town by a bee what's up fool the -
what'd you think of that um
the deep-dish pizza you had at the
airport I like it man also men our
flight was delayed
yeah oh did we do our first flower
suppose me at 9:50 a.m. then after that
got delayed to 3 p.m. then 5 p.m. 7 p.m.
8:30 p.m.
we're like therefore you left the
airport at 8:30 p.m. and yeah luckily we
had enough edible to supply us to the
whole day we had a lot of it's like we
were ready for therefore we have video
games we had candy that snags
whoo yeah edible oh shut up to bearded
vato bearded bot or
beer Novato that's his neighbor he is a
bearded guitar guy I don't know about
his name is now but bearded vato yeah
that fubar bottles three pizzas and in
what one deep dish he told me you fall
asleep in the airport
I post it for a little bit and on the
plane I stayed awake I was watching
movies shut up - who else am i your
Christie Steele
oh well haha California her grandfather
died Cristobal
George the animal Steele oh yeah yeah
really yeah what's up fool
did you do wrestling moves when your
little kids well I just do Sammy
wrestling move bro like on your brothers
my brother would be like the wrestling
villain bro were so bad guy and he would
always my brother angel he will put I
talked about it before he would cook up
a jalapeno bro no but you're waiting
groups would eat when you're like
choking him I put his finger your mouth
no [ __ ] way dude I remember we used
to get you know like the barbed wire
that will get like a wrestling go like
this before heads we get like the the
Harkey and a hairbrush and like you
putting out the barbed wire and scratch
to the four hits like that as you're
hooking her my brother broke he will
fall in a sandwich bag and zip it up run
up to the other person and open it
running their mouth and now this
wrestling moon or the restroom was a
fart book what up pool is a puppy hello
are you
Martin how's it going
nice to meet you here hit these are
really far in a bang
which I got my little kid stuff what's
up we have reverie right here oh yeah
welcome back from her world European
tour oh oh it's crazy
oh yeah beautiful after them oh yeah she
like really did that better in Venice
Beach with in Venice Beach no my dad did
that one the one you did a long time ago
you had a girl with you that was my
sister actually shots to encrypt she's
in the house she filmed the Amsterdam
100 yes you have fans all around perfect
day for that video man yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah that's on that one has a
million something and it's all cuz a
YouTube and SoundCloud YouTube
SoundCloud Facebook Instagram Twitter
everywhere that's a big dog oh yeah I
actually just dropped a video last week
and today it's at 70,000 be wow
yeah it's called ain't [ __ ] yeah that's
cool oh yeah [ __ ] why isn't it on
YouTube and it's also on Spotify Apple
music all that oh yeah music it's there
what do people listen to music listen to
Spotify tick tock tick tock
all the old songs make a comeback yeah
that's all the old songs make a comeback
yeah old song you're gonna come back
like oh [ __ ]
there's a wrapper and here's seven
seconds of it yeah there's a wrapper
that there's a wrapper that made a song
in 1992 and it wasn't until like a
couple of months like a couple of weeks
ago were like the song start popping up
on tick-tock and then people like kids
thought it was a new song and then there
and then the guy comes out he's like oh
I wrote this song 92 what guy is it I
forgot the guy's name little the song's
name is called get the cat get the cat
get the cat get the cat okay
I forgot the guy's name the lone
Ranger's don't get the game but yeah
it's crazy how that sound meter come
back after like [ __ ] 28 Noel yeah
yeah man oh they doing when you heard it
bro hey yo man I think they're playing
your song right now
yeah put the box of the way it's
probably for sure dude yeah I've been
fighting about hip-hop people are late
to men they are lazy I really like I'd
be like I been here - man you ever heard
of a guy named Andre Nikitina he started
when I thought it comedy we didn't know
each other we play with those things
struggles yeah and he performing at the
place where I was there yeah Santa Cruz
then you look at the sound I listen to
like all the people that we've had in
the show I could see a light inspiration
there yeah hell yeah
he's definitely one of my inspiration oh
really yeah I like that song your song
any bad ass thank you yeah thank you
how's everything going with you good I'm
on Hector fighter you know the TV show
head - okay cool awesome I'm in like 2
episodes cool Congrats
your voice is in one of them and then
you have this is one of them like Yoda
in the last hours movie
for that I'm barely enough in that show
to not be annoying bro yeah why people
want more no that's good that's good
that's good and then he's shot as to
Netflix specials yeah and those are cut
we're editing those now that's cool
that's me [ __ ] being the Spanish one
yeah weird Chicago last week
yeah Shia town which I was deep-dish
pizza and oh we're like I wanna
apologize to everybody listen it's ACOG
oh who always thinking about them we
don't know what deep-dish pizza is
because we don't know what deep dish
pizza is he doesn't know he had any
Airport from Pizza Hut yeah yeah no
slice yeah yeah oh yeah oh man I want to
try everything deep-dish now the dish
soap is the road like breakfast and I
like you have to eat breakfast gooey
whatever's around or do you go for the
like the traditional breakfast that they
solders aren't broken you go to a
Denny's for me breakfast
what when when I'm on tour breakfast is
whatever's there yeah I definitely need
breakfast I'm a breakfast eater so
whatever service big and eggs I'll eat
it if it's a shake I'm gonna eat it if
it's a salad I'm gonna eat it because I
don't know when we're gonna stop again
yeah yeah gotta have the breakfast yeah
Michael Blackson the commedia it's too
high they get up right number 12
they gotta Co have the breakfast eggs
bacon pancakes like yeah well you broke
pancake house I love the pancake house
yeah there's a place called original
packing house and I thought was only in
LA but they have like locations no no no
the original is in the original one is
in Portland Oregon the Walker brothers
okay yeah bomb you should check it out
I love pancakes me too this is a pancake
I made those fluffy extra fluffy
pancakes yeah oh my god I was on Twitter
the other day somebody was like I've
never this is the first time I've been
hungry for something I've never tried ha
ha ha ha
you'll be packing for your mom yeah I
make my packets from my own yeah I make
him dry though nobody you made up for
her yeah I'm really dry though for my
mom I never made my mom my mom probably
I was watching the episode about it
would cost the episode of our air ride
on Raymond the episode called slaved
uh-huh and the older girl she's older
now right yeah and Ray started out with
Raymond by shopping by himself with his
mom right and then he's running he runs
into his wife you know so he goes the
twins they left him alone oh I'm gonna
get there's a girl I made a big batch of
Pancakes for them oh yeah and she was
doing a bunch of stuff around the house
uh-huh so they were surprised so after a
while she couldn't pitch them to babysit
but there aren't doing nothing now dude
and she make him practice for grilled
cheese for everybody the kid she's
carrying a big load of laundry blood
huge hand it about cause real hard and
she puts the softener in her hand
of course I made it all like a big deal
that she's asleep good man if you grew
up in like it with your mom working all
day yeah yeah you did all that [ __ ] dog
nobody better than die yeah nobody said
peachy slave you just did it you have to
know right but the the plot was that she
kind of let her do all that for the
mount for the forum Raymond's mom won't
show up no more babysitting yeah that's
crazy and mas yeah God dude you got a do
we did a lot of chores we were little
brother [ __ ] all that that's different
than question than what you asked me
though you said that I ever make my mom
pancakes no the film with pancake the
other one will he ever did all that long
view
no you never asked that no I'm saying
like yeah we I did all that stuff I took
care of my brothers
had to do all that stuff for a long time
but I never made my mom pancakes I was
like what are you going into question
me neither let's talk about this shirt
bro oh I got it at the Burton or like a
long time ago man it looked cool back
then I don't know if it does now will it
light up
are you from LA I am from LA I met some
guy to pick up something at the high
limbo it was yeah it was grimy dirty ass
bottles yeah I went to a ghetto party in
Highland Park in 2006 I saw somebody get
shot it was crazy yeah yeah that's
that's that's when I was in high school
yeah that's that's how it used to be
yeah you went to Burbank High I went to
Franklin High School right but Burbank
is the middle school I didn't go there I
went to a private school called st.
Ignatius it's in Highland Park okay and
then I went to Franklin High School yeah
how cool or nice the public did you get
a continuation like him I did I went to
like a bunch of Asian um I went to the
one of the Highland Park ones for like a
week and then I also went to South
Pasadena for like half a semester
because we stole my grandma's address ha
ha and then I went back to Franklin and
then I got expelled from Franklin always
she graduated from the East LA
occupational Center yeah oh the one
you're going to century in Alhambra oh
yeah cool I was like that's where all
the bad oh that guy just mentioned
enough people show up for one day and
you never saw him again at that school
yeah oh my god my high school is so bad
that like kids from other schools would
jump the fence you fight people and then
they leave they jump the fence right
after like that like they will do that
yeah yep that was like Franklin yeah no
the one though the queer the a field
trip ha we are going being a bunch of
people and a teacher
beat up people from brother buys
basically it was like it was like that
dude
but we had cool future observer even
though it was a bad school because I one
of my teachers her friend worked that
bug in the Jimmy Kimmel show so we like
whoever they don't be lying though maybe
she got a ticket on when I owned I don't
know here we did good and she will I
give us tickets to go to the Jimmy
Kimmel show I'm a very old school that's
sick
yeah bro I was a junior high school an
eighties dog Riley eighties and mad our
field trips were all like industrial bro
we were like at the lowest of the totem
pole far as our factories of a forest
getting in equipment or technology so
our class Dean had to do with the future
I'll give you like a gettin even the
kids before me like just say that the
kids before me yeah ten years before me
I guess they were not expected to learn
anything right so they were given class
like mechanics woodshop [ __ ] auto
shop yeah okay working with well Dean so
my good job my class was [ __ ] up
metal I had metal shop broke when I was
12 years old and we wouldn't had a weld
pool really we too may come to make dust
pans marrow despair really we were soul
at the teacher was our class
we unfolded it with the machine to fold
it yeah and buffets this pre-roll oh I
did with ninja ninja star bro
for three dollars and sharpener and they
found out that I wasn't doing [ __ ]
everyone in the class had to go get a
nope no book he provided and we had to
copy the safety book on that notebook oh
my god that's hilarious dude you're
pretty much it's like an empty class
making all these things itself so get it
back to a field trip you take a
partnership with that guy bro the
teacher mr. Tring gali he was a bar head
teacher finding Ally their fool to go to
the Long Beach Navy shipyard and we just
learned about more jobs that you could
do you pass this class
damn so they were like welding ships
over there bro [ __ ] that's pretty
cool I mean they don't listen now man
three people that without a class showed
up to that art class that day yeah and
ditched and a field trip oh I used to
ditch field trips we took a field trip
to the convention center downtown I mean
my fridge it went to the pantry we
walked all around yeah yeah then we met
them out there the best thing about a
field trip roll with when the school
also brought it brought lunches yeah I
remember the only way they made us go to
the to the future we'd want to go there
that's where a rush hour shot yeah
that's God that anything that's more you
went are they
I always liked had that frozen coke you
had like you freeze a soda when you go
on your Blue Boy
yeah my mom I found my mom's transcripts
one time and saw that she had had a
business class you know in high school
and then I looked at what it was I asked
her about it and she's like God what no
business class they taught you typing
and taking short classes for women only
oh yeah and they were all typing you
know they thought well you could be a
mistake of cheerio mom yeah yeah and
they had home a course but I do make
sure we talk to everybody still oh I had
home in safety book I had to rewrite
Johnny didn't even know how to put the
dishwasher put stuff in the dishwasher
he put there was food all over
everything he's like oh yeah it blew all
that I don't know how he's gotten by
this morning on how to do he doesn't
because he was the same red jacket all
the time
[Laughter]
what's up reverie
when you're next to her my next tour is
going to be in April what are you going
I'm not supposed to talk about it yet
but the plan new album coming though
right I do I'm I'm finishing up my album
right now we're in the last stages of it
I can't say the title yet either because
we haven't released it but it's gonna be
produced by my brother Loudon and it's
gonna be just a banger ass album the
last album we dropped it's called where
the dark side ends we dropped it in
October and it's a very experimental
album and it's really deep and there's a
lot of a lot of different kinds of beats
and a lot of different sounds I'm doing
not really like my typical stuff but
this next album that we're gonna drop
it's just going to be like straight
hardcore rap [ __ ] because that's just a
tip we've been on and I'm excited I'm
excited about it man you been rapping
for a long time I remember the first
time we had you here and I show you that
one little when I first heard about you
concert that was like like two or three
years ago right yeah I'll try to figure
out when it was time flies like yeah you
still live in downtown Elaine I can't in
that condo in a penthouse I just moved
out of the penthouse yeah I'm back back
in a residential area
yeah but the penthouse was really cool
is it good well help you you and your
brother where you moved out yeah yeah
before that we lived on the 4th floor in
that same building
we're like a few months and then before
that we were working out of my grandma
space made with like roaches and mice
and so I'm glad we're on the journey
trying to get out of there you know and
now we have our home studio it's life is
a lot a lot better
you struggle a lot I know I read about
that I didn't know you did drugs yeah
definitely you have struggled with
addiction since I was like 15 basically
since I started doing it I was
struggling with it you know look back
then when I was in high school I didn't
even really think about the fact that I
had a drinking problem or a drug problem
but now when I look back I'm like damn I
threw up almost every time I drank
before you got here we started off the
show because a friend of mine was there
named Isaac who broke his leg at a drunk
college and we try to pop wheelies you
know you're a high school
cool man uh-huh and I forgot on the bike
and broke his ankle and [ __ ] up the
bike that first said we knew how to run
a freeway he said you were a [ __ ]
bike homie at parties or you know I got
into them I guess it would be at parties
and party cruise it senior party cruise
no it was a part of a party crew but I
was just kicking it with like tagging
cruise and I'm skiing with the gang and
in LA we kick it with tagging crew or
with the game I was tagging yeah every
day I try to tag
my school's a lot of tigers - yeah I
would never attack abroad but I was on a
bus one time
yeah I saw fuku came in I was going to
East LA car huh ah that's what comes out
to me man you're a writer
cuz I dunno book yeah yeah I make comedy
dog your name is comedy dog tag you were
hardcore yeah yeah I'm a widow my mom's
to tell that for money
yeah I know number one but no 3031 bus
they want to go to rampart and in the
East LA college full those are these two
kids they would change didn't look at
high school their food part is on a 380
bro a pistol cuz I just tank something
and then I guy [ __ ] he got his marker
and Tyler and [ __ ] crossed it out and
took his gun but he was a rookie bro you
know like he took out the pistol collect
it back and then the bullet got stuck in
here oh my so when he's shot there was
no bullet but then he [ __ ] jammed it
good and one good one came up but he was
a dog yeah that one was the one that
made my ear go thing that's crazy
next stop in a two-hour mob put
everybody into school
there's gonna be a shootout oh but that
tag it was create real a dog yeah
tagging crews turned into gangs pretty
much later on because they were like
trying to protect like their piece
pieces I remember and it was yeah it was
crazy yeah just the beef we would we in
our neighborhood we call them tag
banging crews yeah cuz it they basically
did the same thing that the gangs did
there he said shooting each other
fighting each other all that [ __ ]
amaura there's a CB like this one guys
he skateboard with he was like one of
like the biggest taggers of like
Los Angeles who with atlas oh yeah I
don't know him but of course in my CBS
the Californian bomb squad yeah yeah
[ __ ] legend
yeah here he got Kali a couple years ago
cuz he was doing the the bunnies on the
freeways you remember bunnies the the
blue bunnies the bunnies are the cats
the cat was him yeah that's it he was
like it was a sick-ass skater man you
wanna skate shop in our ham bro yeah
he's 62 much probably alice is like yeah
we got some people here that were that
were who graduate for night in 1983 who
don't know what tagging is is graffiti
we're feeding you ever seen a beat
street here are those things on those
trains that's graffiti here people don't
do little big reveal is no more huh I'm
not sure dude I might try that and I got
scared
which is you know no no no no your
secret also like when I grew up it was
like those commercials about wheel you
know like you turn into like all smoke
we answer that I just I don't want to I
didn't try we deter later on but I have
to watch some [ __ ] hardcore holly was
the drink bro yeah you know there was
one brother for alcohol abuse and it was
a crazy I white man came in bro yeah let
them with a stepfather and he will kick
down the door and the kids that they'll
cut you I've seen those kids are all
scared another blank and he's like
looking at her done this with a mean
face he was drunk
bigot is handing us the little woman
he's posed to us will they beat our
asses up yeah but then it goes if you
have problems with our chick now see it
Wow now we did I mean the skater guys we
will I just go we used to skate hammer
skatepark and we have I got a community
of porno there you see Haider need like
one page we used to go there every time
to look at it and after when your
girlfriend on't jack off in front of
each other because that's weird for
dudes when i go to the strip club and
like have hard-on we got there one day
it wasn't there and then we saw like a
little bit down and there's a homeless
guy put the magazine we were I had look
like crazy David they took of you
community was here right where did it go
my god they were just thing it was
probably the park ranger but then we
just see the [ __ ] and the homeless
guy like now I'm like the [ __ ] by the
tennis courts
he was like hell yeah like [ __ ] a dollar
I got the portal
we didn't have a community portal poor
look at night without kami don't know it
like a CEOs yeah more today what do they
have you know that's gonna mark it you
get paid by grocery co-op yeah over the
portal co-op is geocaching before
geocaching important but we had a guest
here that named ray and he had up
somebody Jackie
busted I wouldn't of his porn oath his
son and I remember we brought him here I
said I don't know read porno for that
that read porno window round bro yeah
that's that's what happens you're in
like back in the day you said sure likes
porno I don't know if we have a dongle
for that you're on the podcast process
Osteen's or what is him a river Ebro
this is the the porn the community porn
collection huh what's up like it sounds
good you will you add those here in Simi
Valley on the IV in a wheelchair we're
doing America's Got Talent oh yeah we're
good but you know what I heard other
people's already getting auditions so I
don't think I got the callback yeah
dammit it happens I lose my way for next
year bro you did it clean set yeah no I
did a clean so it I think too that uh
I'm gonna do it again next year later
I'm broke walk with was like like do for
southpark bro it's Timmy late
that said Fall Brawl do they all get
canceled they don't forget on the
audition
my last joke was the paper-rock-scissors
the the way I did that when I started at
the electoral interview and I kind of
said like I believe that no one's
perfect go applause no one's better than
anybody so I practice that joke I said
paper-rock-scissors no one's better than
anybody we all have flaws so I tried to
little callback you know impress them
did you do it where there are other
people who did interviews to know more
on how to than you a joke did they do
interviews with everybody or did they
just pull certain interview but then you
think they might air your interview and
all that on TV
you never know or a portion even if they
don't because if they share it'd be good
enough yeah yeah I hope so
tell me you shoot only your name was
Nicholas ribcage how's your short the
levity light agenda making it yeah yeah
yeah I made it
I went great going great oh yeah dude
butt off I showed up actually all the
way from East LA Oh Dennis all right
dawg we'll talk to you
okay ready for madam brother the new
manning game oh let's do it to it
all right dawg you're gonna have a
chance I'm kind of blind oh yeah
are you able to you're not able to see
to play okay he tells you what's
happening left like he directs you where
to go haha yeah but you just got beat by
a blind guy No so Flaco is there a
chance that your site's gonna come back
or what's your prognosis right now um I
mean what it is is I just basically I
was like that's not Coleman going on
right so I can see but I just have like
a little like a bad guy my way through
your new jokes have anything to do with
your condition what you've been going
through in the last couple years I
didn't know but I did
I have something written down and
they're ready to go I think but I just
haven't put them on stage oh yeah Flaco
people in the house asking for you to
fight last night yeah yeah yeah like
well what's your where do people follow
you on social media on social media
Isaac Flaco Martinez on Facebook and on
Instagram and on Twitter I'm flock of
seagulls yeah yeah yeah go on Instagram
I changed it actually it's a funny story
like was it quick some kid that was on
tick-tock kept messaging me like saying
that I came a my name's funny flock with
you and I like that name
I'm just gonna like have a name my good
time all right I've became Isaac Sparkle
Martinez hell yeah
begin tick tock race bro I'm sold it to
him I kind of gonna cause he had more
fun
just keep talking yeah put on tick-tock
bro you could you guys hear my son's be
what do you think are people commenting
my son's be can you put it on the i-15
spit some hope I'm gonna provoke these
thoughts in my [ __ ] mind I must keep
going oh oh 24 seconds
yeah here this is only the portion of it
yeah we got a portion but I'm really
finished this beat I think it's gonna
make me speak I wish I could be grabbing
on my feet or maybe on the microphone I
just can't leave this [ __ ] alone I
freestyle all day shoutouts to Isaac on
the beat we up with [ __ ] what is your
brother work in when he makes beats and
sounds for you my brother right now and
the Pro Tools yeah he's he's my son his
reason but he's back on Ableton okay no
sister passed away and he was going to
these rappers so when it was all sad she
passed away so he got into beats to get
up to move on that's cool that's amazing
to be on like he uses FL Studio now yes
I mean South Todd is a really good way
to be taught because if you're
passionate about something you'll do it
you know you don't have to go to school
just to do it it's all
can be camp there is a DJ camp by the
way that sounds fine today
she saw her own DJ camp yeah I bet it'll
be a consular shoplifting school open a
package in the story eat it or if it's
already half eaten the other half
somebody open up a pack of doughnuts
yeah and there's five left
ah they won I see still jeans far Gino
you and frog I'll just do jeans ice bar
knows when skinny jeans first came out
in high school oh my god didn't fancy
boot he made bootleg designer and more
[ __ ] in me how he went to jail real
crime they sold them with labels on them
or something fake labels and all that
stuff damn Jesus why does I just got the
skinny jeans and I knew how to take off
the sensor it's they're easy to take off
and after that put like the other jeans
over and just walk out you took you
could take out the sensor but sometimes
they have glass up down it comes on me
me and my extra friend from high school
you see just go to Urban Outfitters and
just [ __ ] yeah my girlfriend Bonnie
and Clyde team gets there in age of
probably fire versus just the first name
Charlie yeah just yeah what she still
she sees steal clothes too and never we
had a do we're young and we had a home
girl that I knew it's a order they gave
me some jeans bro yeah yeah we would do
that no take orders yeah we hope we had
a home girl that like she see like take
the bus to Hollywood and she worked at
out what's it called American Apparel
and dude she see just that everybody
Jack from there
you too you too are like rock star rocks
and Shantae would take orders from
people Manning up in the Bronx steel and
then when we got caught sorry me and my
cousins were my friends we went to
Target and we're just Jackie CD players
and stuff like that and it was easy and
we kept coming back and then and then we
were walking out one day and he told us
to walk back in and they took us to the
back room and they showed us videos
they're like oh my gosh just told you
stole it no and all scared I was engaged
you just tell the truth I did I was at
the Paseo Colorado in Pasadena oh yeah I
was like 15 or 16 so Colorado man let
the rich get rich here right pH is right
there yes yeah yeah we would we still so
much when I was in high school so that
day we got caught I was I don't give a
[ __ ] like you know how much money I've
stolen from this mall before I was
stealing shirts and pants and basically
we got lazy and we didn't put the
sensors we would take off the sensors
and walk around the shop and put him in
a pockets of another pack yeah but
instead we got lazy that day and we just
put him in the pants and we're gonna
take and we gave him back to the lady
when they take the step back from the
room we were that it was like at that
point like we're a touchable at this
point anyway she found it and then she
said we know you guys stole stuff
there's sensors and pans and we know we
did it and I had the two shirts tucked
in my jeans right here and then the
jeans all the stuff I didn't take the
stuff where is it at what what stuff you
know anyways they called the mall
security and then eventually it was over
just for its fashion or just for fashion
just cuz it was
oh my god you're doing for both fashion
and drugs money bloody - yeah I just I
stole food that's all I ever convenience
store this is what we had no Mike no
money and my mom broke her leg renew our
food stamps and so I went - no I didn't
steal Nutter butters I stole little
pieces of fudge at first but then I
stole started stealing moon pies I stole
this stuff for me and my brothers
parachute pants on that word that came
around my so I could just drop stuff
down there and I know it will come out
the other end
what's yeah I know I got marshmallow
inside it's like yeah blah it's like
chocolate or banana ones for sure come
in yellow and they come in black okay
chocolate and vanilla yeah the popular
the vanilla no no no the chocolate and
then bananas the second one vanilla I
went to the town where they make those
they're everywhere the East Coast thing
right yeah Midwest it's what happened
anyway
no lots of stuff but the the one I got I
didn't get caught but he gave me a look
like next time it's over like okay you
know but this is a convenience store was
small so but I took a whole Red Baron
pizza I put it yeah frozen pizza I put
the whole thing down the back I'm gonna
eat it cold are you gonna cook it up and
take it home cook it for me and my
brothers that's what I was my brother
Johnny used to go I don't know if he's
watching right now but he is to go with
me and he would kind of I don't know if
he knew I was stealing at the time and I
don't know if he remembers any of this
cuz he doesn't remember I hope that
yeah it was and I didn't go I didn't go
back after that I just did Johnny dig I
don't think he ever took anything he
just before I got David never went with
us he was too young we would have gotten
caught
johnny was like 2 years younger than me
so that's so he was about seven I don't
know I don't think he knew what was
going on I think he just he just enjoyed
what I brought back least someone skinny
bro huh okay about you but it's like
sitting in the back of my jackets and I
see you you know it from the inside ice
like cut right here so inside you made
out first to [ __ ] dude that's crazy
oh it was easy man it was too easy dude
shouts will do go where those Chinese
past this weekend oh yeah oh my god
Bruce Lee where the black tee shirt and
these pants then that those baggy pants
was another screen in the bottom but the
black drop stream Patrick its jogger
ones he's wearing that black vans with
no socks yeah so he look one of those
chubby Asian guys we can carry water up
about him bro to the dragon oh my god
every go is weird tonight today he's
missing today but you goes up boys doing
shows with Larry bubbles Brown yeah
everybody's brought hope the more the
bunch of shows up north I'm gonna make
my 200 here 150 there 75 was gonna add
up
oh yeah but you know interview for the
job a podcast legendary comedian more
saw he's blind now
really
you know Mort saw em ort as LG s a ul
yes he's considered a a political
comedian no humorous humorous humorous
satirist satirist what are your satirist
no mo Gemini was so reverend hell yeah
who are the rappers you came up with
back like in the LA scene or other
rappers or I mean I was part of a scene
and there was a lot of people who and we
started yeah yeah very few of us have
made it out and over the years I
realized that that's just part of
growing up growing up you know I know
everybody's gonna make it exactly and we
have families yeah people have families
or people just don't want to put in the
work or it's a lot of work bro yeah yeah
yeah so I mean I still work with my
brother and my brothers who I started
with he's always recorded me since I
basically first dropped my first mixtape
which was in 2009 those long 10 years
now we've been working together so it's
really crazy and actually szostak
Gavilan cuz Gavilan is somebody that I
started with too
she's a really dope rapper and I mean
her have kept in touch over the years
we've done three tours in Europe
together we've done an American tour
we're working on the album together yeah
but those are the two people that I'm
like really still yeah so close with you
what does your brother tour with you and
do stuff with you on the road to or how
does that work when you're do you rap
over a track that he's prepared for you
or what what happens how does that work
sometimes he comes with me on tour
definitely we were just like he did for
me in San Francisco this last weekend
we've been all over Europe together
we've been in just we've been in a lot
of countries and Europe together and
done a lot of european tours but i work
with other producers very few I'm very
picky with who I work with I like to
keep my circle very small but the
majority of the stuff that I pull out is
definitely over over Louden's beats and
the way we usually work is that he makes
a bunch of beats and when I feel like
writing I do
go into the studio and pick whichever B
fits my mood the most he just said hey
here's all the stuff I've been playing
with and then you pick and choose what
you like yeah and sometimes I'll tell
him what I want him to make me cuz I'll
be in a certain mood you know
yeah and or else once in a great while I
will write a song over another beat and
then he'll make a beat for that the kind
of father says yeah that's cool yeah man
oh yeah that's awesome that's cool was
it the new album drop or you can't
imagine either we don't have a set day
but it's gonna be within the next like
three months I would say hell yeah yeah
soft food days Lisa oh yeah
this Tuesday rizal national news on it
too in Hollywood Laugh Factory Latino
night Eric Rivera is trying to make that
a solid night everyone yeah
brownish live go follow brownish live on
instagram you can get free tickets to
the show Felipe's on the show Martin's
on the show Eric Rivera's on the show I
think ADA Rodriguez is on the show Chris
Garcia Carlos Garcia I think Frank
Castillo it'll be there but anyway so
come support come out and show the left
factory that you want this night there
Felipe isn't at Laugh Factory much
anymore either so you can get free
tickets on Instagram they have in their
bio a little Eventbrite ticket link and
you sign up right there you can get free
tickets and he doesn't do free shows
anymore
either's and if you want to if you
wouldn't do it even longer
there's another show at the end at the
end of that show Ruben Paul called on a
weekly show take your that's true March
6 Toppenish Washington Toppenish that's
the Yakima Pasco area legends casino
City that's legends casino that's next
Friday oh yeah
and then Pasadena you're doing another
show it locally but it's in Spanish
March
March 8th Icehouse that's I think
tickets are almost gone for that Midland
Texas Austin Texas coming up also also
March 27th and 28th that's a big show
with earthquake Bruce Bruce Loney love
Felipe a bunch of people that's Midland
Texas Austin Texas and Coachella
California April 4th spotlight 29 casino
oklahoma city oklahoma Bricktown comedy
club april 9th through 11th oxnard
levity live April 30th through May 3rd
that's already on sale ins gonna sell
out fast and check all dates at Felipe's
Worldcom follow him at felipe as far as
a comedian on instagram or funny felipe
on snapchat and Twitter what's up how
are you thanks I am having a Los Angeles
Show on May 9 and I'm gonna be
performing at the cycle DeMaio event and
then I'm about to be in Scottsdale
Arizona on march 19th I'm hitting
Seattle Washington on April 30th and
then I'm going to be in Greece in
September performing yes performing at
the off the hook festival that's awesome
yeah yeah what'd you go so on March 3rd
who do I waiting over why Hawaii I'm
gonna try to find a spot out there
what's it called March 6 Washington with
you guys and then this Friday I'm doing
a show in Boyle Heights and then yeah
where's that short Boyle Heights it's
all the Friday medical time wait no they
they got they got they changed the
promoters so it's like a brand new
revamp show same area so they they they
kicked out whoever was like you know
producing the show before and now it's
called feed em feed em if Fridays
English my solo anime homey yeah they'll
be fine
of course its people allenbys oh yeah
dude no one
yeah I miss OMB
my my favorable real beating cheese
burrito there bro
that place is good man rest in peace
little blue eyes what up next to the
Holland by police station next to the
theater it's now a church in our church
in front of that in the middle of the
church and and the Hollenback Youth
Center there's a attending zero talking
and they have beat inches they have
although all the burritos are you think
about your high combination the
combination was not ready meat and bean
and cheese and will they have a hot dog
but we don't really a [ __ ] fried hot
dog you put them up there was cheese and
beans and they will fry any burrito you
can bring your own burrito to deep-fry
oh well they grow deep right we don't
eat there anymore but I miss that yeah
red sauce is so good and the I'm a fat
do you know fat people we have my ice
[ __ ] Hale
Rosemead yeah man
yeah and the only sort Pepsi Cola Pepsi
yeah have seen like having sex with a
man but with a nice penis but then like
just gets more like a earthwork because
you do not hold the gas dude
yeah the bubbles are gone pretty quick
yeah yeah that's cold bro you talk well
you get that big thing go as soon as you
put the they put your flyer brother
don't want pancakes after that short
rule let's go man green green blue green
Bloods let their pancakes
what's up people find your social media
reverie love everywhere Instagram
Twitter Facebook YouTube reverie love
calm and then my musics wherever you
listen to music Spotify title Apple
music these are whatever reverie
oh yeah sure to see the Bustos bad aim
[ __ ] you're fat you what your name was
real big Satori and a bright Figaro real
Martinez Frank Avila Brian Figueroa for
New England what up dog oh yeah this was
talking about that a New England while
where he's from
in Boston area Delaware area East Coast
he said that that changing room lady
steals all the clothes
What's Up boo oh man shut up to that
restaurant I went to eat in Santa
Clarita bro College Arita that's a trip
oh my god Brody they stepped it up a
notch brother hung
yeah all right I see I became vegan
there it was just the daughter right the
daughter husband she became vegan then
they serve vegan I say some of the
dishes the dad was like a healthy angel
grow my brother fans thank you very much
for being in the show that's fine thank
you for a bro to go that pit bull you
know man like it hurts after watching
that show dr. pimple popper I'm like I
don't want to get
[Laughter]